gut wir haben eine weitere sendung zum
verhältnis von philosophie und physik
mit dr cavlina und wir haben im
hintergrund albert einstein der sich da
an die stirn ist aber nicht so dass er
sagt ja sondern eher so dass sagt ich
denke und wir wollen jetzt auch ein
bisschen uns auf die spuren von albert
einstein begeben und wenn man albert
einstein hört denkt man zugleich an die
relativitätstheorie deswegen meine
anfrage an sie was sind in die
implikationen der relativitätstheorie
auch jetzt gerade philosophischer natur
auch darüber geht es wie bei den banken
mechanik recht verschiedene ansichten
nicht also einerseits hat einstein
selber aus der relativitätstheorie die
sozusagen grundüberzeugung hergeleitet
das raum und zeit 1 4 dimensionale
einheit bilden nicht als solches ist
raum und zeit und in drin sich
miteinander verbunden sind und unsere
subjektiven kategorien von zeit also
gegenwart zukunft und vergangenheit
nicht anders zu interpretieren sind als
räumliche kategorien von hier und
woanders sprich also unsere wahrnehmung
dass die gegenwart irgendwie wirklicher
ist als die vergangenheit und noch viel
wirklicher als die zukunft die es nach
einstein physikalisch nicht haltbar es
ist sozusagen alle zeiten sind gleich
reel existieren objektiv auf genau der
gleichen ebene und der unterschied
zwischen vergangenheit und zukunft
erklärt sich rein subjektiv aus unserer
wahrnehmung aus darum wie wir also am
funktionieren in diesem raum zeit
kontinuum die haben keinerlei objektive
gültigkeit
dem haben philosophen und zeigte er
widersprochen nicht man kann natürlich
auch versuchen diese relativitätstheorie
anders interpretieren
aber es gibt schon eine sache in der
relativitätstheorie die wirklich sehr
gut wieder ständig ist und die aufhält
es ist nämlich einfach in der
relativitätstheorie nicht nur keinen
objektiven begriff von gegenwart gibt
nicht also es gibt keine jetzigen
zeitpunkt den ich auf irgendeinen weit
entfernten ort übertragen könnte sondern
jede annahme einer solchen verhältnisse
ist nicht also wenn ich annehme ich
könnte sagen wann jetzt auf dem jupiter
oder sirius ist führt widersprüchen
heißt also es führt zu physikalischen
widersprüchen und das ist natürlich ein
starkes argument dagegen zu sagen
anzunehmen dass es objektiv so etwas wie
gegenwart nehmen könnte
das heißt wäre das sind er diese
position des präsentismus das also alle
zeiten auf einer ebene zur gleichen zeit
in anführungsstrichen also gegenwart
vergangenheit und zukunft jetzt nicht
unter logisch irgendwie gestaffelt
vorliegen und erstrecken aufs ja ja also
ich nenne es lieber also im englischen
gibt es den begriff des block universe
es nicht also das sozusagen die
zeitliche ausdehnung eben genau wie eine
räumliche ausdehnung sozusagen das ganze
raumzeit ein klotz ein raum zeit wurde
sagt man ja auch manchmal merkt bei
präsentismus ist immer so ein bisschen
doppeldeutig nicht also sozusagen
man will ja gerade die den begriff der
gegenwart aus der aus der grundlagen der
dritte der physik entfernen aber ja also
das ist die grundidee
wie gesagt man kann argumentieren und es
ist natürlich immer dann die frage nicht
also wenn wir annehmen dass einstein
recht hat und das sozusagen alle zeiten
gleichberechtigt sind woher kommt
ländern unsere subjektive wahrnehmung
von dem absolut grundsätzlichen
unterschied zwischen vergangenheit und
zukunft warum es in vergangenheit und
zukunft dampf für uns so grundsätzlich
verschieden wenn sie physikalisch
angeblich völlig gleichwertig
und da gibt es sehr interessante fragen
dazu zu stellen
und da glaube ich tut sich eben auch
wieder die verbindung zur interpretation
der konnten mich ja nicht auf weil es
natürlich oder nicht natürlich es meiner
meinung nach
sozusagen ein quantenmechanisch phänomen
ist ein phänomen unserer wahrnehmung der
quantenmechanischen welt nämlich diesen
in determinismus der kommt für mich
erwischen welt die den unterschied
zwischen vergangenheit und zukunft
begründet und das ist sozusagen die
parallele zwischen der interpretation
der relativitätstheorie und der
interpretation der quantenmechanik genau
die ist dass man genau so wie man sagt
dass die kategorie dagegen war hat eine
subjektive wahrnehmung ist in ein
objektiv koexistieren allen zeiten
gleichberechtigten universum so ist auch
die wahrnehmung unserer realität eine
subjektive in einer objektiv
existierenden continum von unendlich
vielen möglichkeiten also genauso wie
wir die wirklichkeit als gegenwart
wahrnehmen und nicht als block universum
zu nehmen die wirklichkeit auch als eine
realität war nicht als ein vielzahl von
verschiedenen möglichkeiten
naja da sieht man dass die albert
einsteins relativitätstheorie durchaus
handfeste philosophische fragen nach
sich zieht die unsere und logie
betreffen
vielleicht ganz zum schluss noch die
frage nach dem verhältnis von spezieller
und allgemeiner relativitätstheorie was
ist denn so der unterschied
die grundidee der allgemeine
relativitätstheorie ist das raum und
zeit nicht fest
sozusagen ein starrer am sind wie sie
also seid juden immer waren
und eben auch noch in der speziellen
relativitätstheorie sind sondern dass
ich selber dynamisch sind dass sich
selber sich verändern können
das ist sozusagen widerspricht unseren
rund institutionen von raum und zeit
natürlich auch total im endeffekt die
empirisch wahrnehmen wahrnehmbaren
effekt davon ist dass ich sozusagen
die entfernung zwischen gegenständen
verändern können ohne dass ich die
bieten stände wirklich bewegen also die
messung von raum und zeit ist nicht ein
für allemal festgelegt sondern die hängt
davon ab was drumherum passiert
physikalisch raum und zeit verhalten
sich sozusagen wie so ein elastisches
gummi gewebe was also zum beispiel in
schwingungen versetzt werden kann ist
die kastrations- wellen die erst auf
experimenten nachgewiesen sind nicht das
bedeutet einfach dass wenn irgendwo im
innenraum zeiten etwas sehr heftiges
passiert nicht also wie zb supernovas
oder kollegen kollidierende sterne dann
wird das raum-zeit-kontinuum selbst in
schwingungen versetzt und diese
schwingungen können wir messen indem
sozusagen einen ein lineal nicht stehen
konnte ich wähle ich die gleiche länge
hat sondern verschiedene längen
das sind das ist die grundidee der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie und auch
da ist wieder die frage wie ist das dann
zu interpretieren bedeutet das dass
sozusagen raum eines raumzeit eine
substanz ist die eben bestimmte
physikalische eigenschaften art oder
bedeutet es umgekehrt was einsteins
interpretation war das sozusagen
raumzeit wiederum nur ein physikalischer
effekt ist dieser felder die irgendwie
existieren unabhängig von raum und zeit
und die unsere kategorien von raum und
zeit überhaupt erst gruppe produziert
deswegen hat einsteins
relativitätstheorie genannt weil er eben
die interpretation hatte dass die dass
die theorie du weißt dass raum und zeit
keine absoluten kategorien sind sondern
selber nur relativ sind dass wir sie
sich sozusagen über messen als effekt
von anderen physikalischen vorgängen das
ist denke ich ein durchaus welt
erschütterndes bild eine einzig die
unsere alltags intuition auf jeden fall
sehr in schwingungen bringt könnte man
sagen
vielen dank für diese kundige einführung
diese erklären diese sehr komplexen
zusammenhängen wir verabschieden uns bei
unseren zuschauern bis zu einem nächsten
sendung ja
[Musik]